by insomnia abdul-rahman is the
Kurdistan Regional Government
representative to the United States and
comes from a long line of leaders in the
Kurdish community Bayan welcome to the
show thank you for having me
so I'm very excited to talk to you
because we've talked a little bit about
the Kurds here and this is not a topic
or a people that get really any play in
the United States I talked to Senator
John McCain a bit about the Kurds I've
had a CIA operative who was in Kurdistan
and in Iraq talked a bit about it
but can you give me sort of Kurds 101
who are these people
where are they and and what is the
history of these people well I'll go
into ancient history people may have
heard of the meets or the Meade Empire
which was also at the time of the
Persian Empire
so we Kurds are the descendants of the
meat's another reference to the Kurds
but not as Kurds as such is in the Bible
one theory is that the three wise men
who went to see Jesus at his birth that
they were actually from Kurdistan so
there are lots of references to the
Kurds or our ancestors in various
documents or so Alexander the Great
fought some of his battles when he was
invading the Middle East in Kurdistan as
well so lots and lots of historical
references but jumping to more recent
history to 19th and 20th century
Kurdistan was essentially divided
between four countries after the second
of the first world war President Woodrow
Wilson of the United States put forward
the idea of self-determination as a way
for the nations in Europe and the Middle
East to break away from the old empires
and to determine their own future and we
of course supported President Wilson's
theory because under that
self-determination would have meant
independence for Kurdistan but the
powers at the time the French the
British
they were the Empire's they wanted to
break up the Ottoman Empire they wanted
to create these different states in the
Middle East and so the people of
Kurdistan would divide it up and that's
the borders those are the borders that
we have with today so there are Kurds in
Iraq Iran Turkey and Syria right so just
to be clear for people that lose some of
the history
so the Ottoman Empire basically ran the
entire thing and then and then the
British came in carved up some of this
stuff so during the carving of this how
did it happen that Kurdistan didn't come
to be well in one set of negotiations
immediately after the first world war
there was going to be an independent
Kurdistan and then the European powers
who were the superpowers at the time
made another deal whereby the French
would have Syria the British would have
Iraq and they decided to divide up the
Kurds so that we would always be a
balancing force so for example in Iraq
they put Sunnis and Shias together and
they wanted the Kurds as the third
element to balance the other two also
there's a lot of oil and gas in
Kurdistan and that was another reason to
carve it up but really says the
beginning of the 20th century we Kurds
have been divided up between these four
borders and unfortunately those
countries weren't democracies they were
dictatorships or authoritarian basically
not free societies so to be kurdish to
speak Kurdish to talk about Kurdish
rights basically was a no-no and got
everybody into trouble including many of
my relatives from my grandfather onwards
yeah so I want to talk a little bit
about your family history but just to
wrap up the the historical portion of
this so right now the Kurdish regional
government exists and that's that's who
you work for and they exist in Iraq but
the goal ultimately is that what will
become Curtis enter what you hope will
come Kurdistan is going to encompass
more area than you guys control right
now is that is that fair to say when we
talk about independence in my government
where are we talking about Iraqi
Kurdistan of course cards everywhere
want independence but officially I'm
only talking about Iraqi Kurdistan the
Kurdistan Regional Government now
controls all of the Kurdish territory in
Iraq officially we administer only part
of it but after we pushed Isis out when
they attacked us we now have control of
all of kurdistani areas with anyone and
we do want independence our president
President Barzani has called for a
referendum on self-determination to be
held this year and I'm pretty sure that
the vast majority of the Kurdish people
in Iraq will vote for independence that
doesn't mean that we're going to declare
independence straight away it just means
that our leadership has the mandate or
the authority to negotiate so why would
someone that's Kurdish not vote for
independence what would be their
reasoning I have no idea you're just
assuming that not everybody's going to
there might be somebody with some good
you know big deals or something with
Iraq that wants to remain an Iraqi
citizen or something yes but you know
Curtis on is multicultural and
multi-religious so it were not all cut
out i'm kurdish of course and I'm a
Sunni Muslim and we make up the majority
in Kurdistan but in Iraqi Kurdistan we
have Christians they are Assyrian
Chaldean we have yes Eady's we have show
bugs car gays and Arabs as well so maybe
some of those communities may think that
well you know we would rather be under
Iraqi Authority but I'm confident that
the vast majority of people who will
vote in the referendum would rather have
self-determination than be under the
authority of Baghdad I'm reminded of our
election here in 2007 when Joe Biden who
was
at the time running against Barack Obama
in the Democratic primary and they were
asking well what do you do with Iraq and
he said well Iraq actually needs to be
partitioned between the Sunni the Shia
and the Kurds and everyone kind of
laughed at him because it just sounded
so ridiculous you know I mean we were in
the midst of this war that we were
trying to get out of but in a way he was
right right I mean having this split by
more sensible ethnic lines would would
lead to the state that you want to be
honest
Iraq has never worked as a sedate it was
created about a hundred years ago 1992 a
hundred years ago it has had a history
of violence within the countries of
violence against the government between
the government and the people
history violence against neighbors it's
been a destabilizing force in the Middle
East and internally the people of Iraq
have suffered not just the Kurds the
Arabs too you know we've had repeated
acts of genocide and the worst period
was of course under Saddam saying when
we had chemical bombardment repeated
acts of genocide against the Barzani's
the faiis halabja the anniversary of
Halabja is on the 16th of march by the
way so we've had this kind of suffering
and violence in Iraq ever since it was
created it's never gelled it's true that
under Saddam saying there was less
public violence that you see now now we
see these huge suicide bombings and you
know there was almost a civil war around
2006 and 7 in Iraq between the shears
and the Sunnis but there was a huge
amount of repression and violence under
Saddam's just that the world didn't know
about it so is that the irony of what's
going on here I feel like there's a
little bit of rewriting of history going
on where people keep saying that America
led to Isis now clearly had Saddam been
there right now there's every reason to
think he would have kept Isis down if
they had started percolating up but
people sort of forget how horrible
Saddam in the bath party what they were
doing to dissidents and free thinkers
and certainly the Kurds 1988 gas
the Kurds etc people sort of have
rewritten this where it somehow comes
off that Saddam was almost a good guy
which is the furthest thing that he ever
was I agree with you it's very
frustrating that we see that for many
people the history of Iraq began in 2003
I wish it began in 2003 it didn't it
began you know 8090 years earlier and as
I said Iraq has had a history of Cadet
has a violent transfer of power from one
government to another lots and lots of
people disappearing people buried alive
I mean the the horrors and the violence
in Iraq are the precursor to what we're
seeing today and I don't think the
United States can be blamed for
everything there are mistakes that the
United States has made absolutely but
ultimately we Iraqis need to also be
held responsible for the failure of the
state Iraq is a failed state and it
should never have been created it was
created and a dictator managed to keep
it together but who wants to live under
a dictatorship reference for us Kurds
Iraq has failed us repeatedly I can't
think of what good thing we have seen
out of being part of Iraq and so why on
earth shouldn't we be able to choose and
determine our future just like the
people of Quebec in Canada the people of
Scotland in the United Kingdom they have
had referendums on independence
ultimately they decided to stay with
their countries that's fine that's their
choice
give us the choice that's all we're
asking for right so that's the
fascinating part of this all you guys
are asking for is the choice and then as
you said most Kurds probably will vote
for their own state but you just want
the choice to do it I'm curious what do
you think of you know right before the
American withdrawal from Iraq a few
years ago you know there were free
elections in Iraq by by most measures
things seem to be turning for the better
and then I guess the vacuum that existed
after we left things turned for the
worse
do you think had we stayed
not to say we should have stayed not to
say we should have went in in the first
place
but do you think facts being as they are
had we stayed would the Kurds and the
Iraqis be in a better position right now
I definitely think that US influence in
Iraq diminished dramatically after the
withdrawal of the troops there was an
attempt by the United States to reach an
agreement with the then Prime Minister
Maliki to leave a force in Iraq but the
United States I think wanted immunity
for his forces and Baghdad was not
willing to give it so there was an
attempt to leave a residual force there
and that would have made all the
difference because really in the Middle
East I'm afraid we are still at the
stage of evolution where force is what
gives you Authority you know shared
values these kind of values of freedom
and liberty and freedom of speech
they're wonderful but frankly they're a
luxury in much of the Middle East it's
has got the gun that counts and so the
withdrawal of the US forces completely
diminished US influence absolutely
that's inevitable meanwhile the
neighbors they're making the most of the
vacuum yeah so how did the Kurds come to
be the way everything that I see about
the Kurds remain I mean I literally see
pictures of women fighters women that
look like western women fighting Isis
and we'll get to that in a little bit
but how did the the ethos of the Kurds
where you guys do respect minorities as
you said the Yazidis and many others and
there is a feeling that Western values
are good
within the Kurdish community how did
that actually flourish amongst so many
places that you're surrounded by that it
doesn't flush at all um I think we have
a tradition part of our heritage part of
our culture is to be looking for
peaceful coexistence and so Christians
Yezidis many other minority
shucks khakis Kurds Arabs we have lived
side by side in peace and harmony and we
have that tradition I mean even now when
it's Christmas I will phone my Christian
friends and Kurdistan and congratulate
them and when it's our festivities they
will do the same my mother she was born
in the 1940s in Sinjar
she was from a Muslim family the first
school that she attended was run by
Christian nuns and so this culture of
coexistence has been part of our
heritage and it's just very normal it's
not something that's imposed by law or
by government we do have laws in place
we do have quotas for example for our
Parliament where the minorities have
allocated an allocated number of seats
whether they get the votes or not they
get those seeds we have laws and so on
but actually more important that is part
of our culture and I think that's
something we're proud of and we want to
defend and when you have you're
surrounded by authoritarian regimes that
destroy everything you want to be with
the underdog we are the underdogs memory
to be with fellow persecuted people and
I think there's that sort of idea of
common good that we all share what why
do you think this story I mean this
whole story of your people is completely
ignored in the West people just simply
don't talk about it which is exactly why
I wanted to talk about it why do you
think that is well first of all thank
you
Pepa for talking about it you're welcome
I suppose there are many reasons
what is the Kurdish story is complicated
you know as much as I might try to
simplify but I also want to be truthful
to the story it's a complicated story
and I think that makes it difficult the
other is frankly speaking money right to
really run an effective campaign where
you win people to your side you need
money you need to propagate soft power
we need universities to be teaching
about Kurdistan we need advertising
saying come to Kurdistan is a wonderful
tourism destination we need heavy
lobbying particularly a country like the
United States and it's such a vast
country everywhere not just in
Washington DC that needs money and we've
never had that kind of money but you
know there are very very successful
examples I would say Israel you know has
massive support in the United States the
Jewish community here is very proactive
of course the community is self is
proactive but it takes money which we
don't have so I was going to mention
actually the Israel situation because I
think it's sort of interesting you know
in America and in most of the world we
spend so much time talking about the
israeli-palestinian conflict and the
wider conflict with the Arab world and
to me it seems that it's the only reason
we talk about it so much and we're
talking about the most ridiculously tiny
piece of land on earth is because it's
simple to frame the argument it's Jews
verse Arabs or Jews verse Muslims
however you you want to frame it and I
think the story of the Kurds because
it's confuse Muslim are you know it
makes it much more confusing much less
people don't understand the sunni-shia
divide so that it really has a lot to do
with just defining what the actual
problem is in a sort of simple way
that's true and I think one very
worrying factor that's we're seeing now
in the United States but also in Europe
is this fear of the Muslim the fear that
every Muslim is out to kill us you know
and fortunately that is not true I know
that might be the perception and I'm not
denying that there are Muslims who want
to kill Americans or Europeans and Isis
is has a distorted version of Islam that
it wants to propagate but the vast
majority of Kurds are Muslim but I would
say when moderate we believe in
coexistence is part of our culture we
look to the west and we admire the west
we admire the progress the technology
the advances in science and health
putting a man on the moon hopefully a
woman on the moon soon a so on and we
admire that and we want part of it it
doesn't mean that we're going to let go
of our culture and our heritage and you
know become I don't know palm beach or
something Kurdistan will be Kurdistan
and we'll have its culture but why not
share what we have with you and you with
us and we can both benefit from it yeah
so in a weird way it almost sounds to me
like the society you're what you're
trying to build in some ways is so
reverse of what goes on in that part of
the world it's hard for people to wrap
their brains around that this could
happen it almost would exacerbate it
would show people Wow Iraq really did
fail cuz look what's happening in Iraq
but meanwhile somehow the Kurds did it
so it really flips everything on its
head that you know that this flower
could happen in the middle of the desert
I think Kurdistan is the success story
in Iraq and it needs to be nurtured I
think your description of it as a flower
is apt I think it is a flower but like
every flower it needs to be tended it
needs to be nurtured it can easily be
knocked down and this is really where we
are today I should say though Kurdistan
is an island of stability and peaceful
coexistence
but there are other places in the Middle
East - I don't want to make out let's
just go to Sun if you look at Lebanon of
course they have problems I don't want
to but Lebanon has Arabs Druze
Christians Muslims you know there are
other places around the Middle East it's
just that they're not allowed to thrive
and this is where the United States can
really play a role nurture these places
that do look to the West that do want to
share values of human rights and liberty
and want to do business for the United
States for example but they need
nurturing because we are surrounded by
hostile attitudes yeah you know it's
funny I think actually in a way you're
proving my point because we don't talk
about Lebanon either which yeah
there are Christians and Muslims in
Lebanon that are that are getting along
so every time something's good happening
in the Middle East for some reason we
seem unable to talk about it
but let's talk a little bit about your
family history because you come from a
long line of people in your family that
have helped the Kurdish movement for a
long time and and you've paid the price
personally so can you tell me a little
bit about that sure I guess a good
starting point is my grandfather my
maternal grandfather my family is
originally from Sinjar which most people
know as a Yazidi town but actually in
the old days it used to be mixed Muslims
Christians Yazidis Turkmen and others
and my grandfather was very prominent
played a very prominent role in Sinjar
advocating for people's rights and so on
and he and many many of my relatives
including male female and children
relatives have been imprisoned exiled
tortured various things basically
because they stood out stood up for
Kurdish rights then my father and mother
both of them also played a very
important role in the Kurdish liberation
movement my father was actually in the
leadership of one of the political
parties and he was a Peshmerga in his
young days carrying arms and fighting
the Iraqi regime at the time then he
evolved into a really a statesman and a
diplomat my mother was a housewife and
the mother
those are needed - those are needs in
society dismisses people like that but
she was also a campaigner I mean she
really campaigned for Kurdistan and for
people's rights and my father at one
time was kind of prime minister in exile
of of a Kurdistan Regional Government in
exile this was in the 1970s and then in
the late 90s he became the deputy prime
minister of the Kurdistan region and at
the time that he was killed in 2004 he
was deputy prime minister so you said
that my family had
pay the price we have but I don't want
to exaggerate my family situation
because many many Kurdish people have
suffered enormously and my family is
just like this my in February 2004 my
elder brother and my father were killed
in a suicide bombing by Islamist
extremists along with many other people
and of course it had a huge impact on my
family on me personally and so today in
my work I'm very proud of the legacy
that I've inherited and I feel that I
have a very high standard to live up to
so I have to make sure I don't let down
what they built up and that I continue
to serve my people the way they did and
the way they wanted me to
you